hello i hope you enjoyed the field trip
to koenigsberg
and now the time has come to look into
algorithmic ideas behind genome
sequencing
we have a lot of territory to cover but
the good news
is that we will be joined today by dr
sean farm
one of the leading experts on genome
sequencing
i wanted to start from a question who
are these people
who look like criminal on mug shots
and why they appear on the same slide
with three great mathematicians from
three different centuries
by the end of this lesson you will learn
the answer to this question
but some of you have already guessed
that we are interested in these people
because they are interested in their
genomes
you can think about the human genome as
a 3 billion nucleotide long book
written in ac gt alphabet
and some of you may think that since
humans are so involved
then the genome must be the longest
genome known this is not true
there are genomes that are hundreds
times
longer than the human gene as we speak
there are thousands of genome sequencing
projects that is being conducted
all over the world biologists are
interested in genome sequencing
because they can learn a lot from
studying the genome
for example they can understand the
function
of a human gene by studying a similar
gene
in fly or even in bacteria and of course
there are
numerous applications of genome
sequencing in medicine
agriculture biotechnology and many other
fields genome sequencing started
in 1977 when
walter gilbert and frederick sanger
invented the first
dna sequencing technologies usually
great discovery wait for two to three
decades
before they awarded the nobel prize
in this case the noble committee waited
just
three years before it awarded the nobel
prize to sanger and gilbert
it was obvious that this discovery will
have
enormous implications for science
however as great as this discovery was
sequencing technology invented by sanger
and gilbert
was very expensive it would cost three
billion dollars
to sequence the human genome with this
technology
it did not stop biologists who in 1990
started human genome project that
is still up to this day the largest
collaborative research project in
biology
the goal of this project was to sequence
human genome
in 15 years and to deliver it to the
public by the year
2005. in 1997
there was an unexpected entry into
human genome sequencing craze craic
venter
founded a private company celerio
genomics with his
stated goal to sequence his human genome
ahead
of public human genome project
and this was great for everybody because
the race
to sequence the human genome intensified
and by the year 2005 years ahead of
scheduler
the human genome was sequenced
immediately afterwards
biologists started sequencing many other
genomes
and here you see all nine mammalian
that were sequenced in the next 10 years
it looks like great set of animals and
a large number of biology biological
sequencing problem
obviously biologists was very busy
sequencing these genomes
however they wanted to sequence
thousands of genome
and in the framework of existing
technology
it was just not feasible it the existing
technology was very expensive
and that's why the number of companies
all over the world started a race to
invent
new next generation sequencing
technologies
they succeeded and they reduced the cost
of sequencing by
orders of magnitude as a result
they can now move from a sequencing of
reference human genome
to sequencing personal human shapes
reference human genome represents an
average genome of
average human genome but we want to find
the differences
between genomes of different humans and
this difference may appear to be small
in particular between every two human
you expect to see
roughly one mutation in thousands
nucleotides however these differences
may be
extremely important as they are
responsible for
thousands of genetic diseases
personal medicine and personalized
genomics have
important implications in medicine and
in 2010
nicholas walker has become the poster
child
of personalized genomic his life was
saved
by genome sequencing poor child went
through
thousands of surgeries because doctors
failed to diagnose
his condition afterwards they decided to
sequence his genome
and found a rare mutation in a gene
linked to a defect in his immune
system as a result immunotherapy saved
the life of the child and uh with this
human genome sequencing cost falling
down we expect that
very soon the cost of sequencing the
human genome will
fall under 1 000 mark
as a result sequencing genomes will
probably become
as routine as x-ray today
at the same time there are numerous
projects to sequence
various species and in 2010 biologists
started
10 000 genome projects to sequence 10
000 vertebrate species just think about
this
a single human genome in 2000 10
000 genomes in the year 2010.
to accomplish this genomic revolution we
need
to develop algorithmic techniques for
sequencing genomes
and in the next segment dr sean farm
will tell you
how it can be done